[Applaudissements]
applaudissement nourri pour accueillir
voluminières delinsky
presque un an après le début du conflit
avec la Russie il y a presque un an jour
pour jour il s'adressait pour la
première fois à ce Parlement européen
par visioconférence et le voilà donc
en personne devant les parlementaires
en compagnie de la présidente Maltesse
Roberta mezzola qui va s'adresser à lui
après cette standing ovation parce que
c'est quand même un parlement qui a fait
le plein alors qu'il n'y avait pas
vraiment qui fait ça le comble
effectivement tout le monde est là pour
rendez-vous là qui est venu le voir
l'applaudir en personne des mesures de
sécurité renforcées comme jamais autour
de ce rond-point Schuman autour aussi du
Parlement européen qu'on appelle le
caprice des dieux et voilà la présidente
qui va parler et s'adresser à ce
président ukrainien
nous sommes réunis ici aujourd'hui pour
une occasion historique pour accueillir
le président de l'Ukraine volodimeki au
Parlement européen c'est un moment
extraordinaire
à une époque extraordinaire
cela fait presque un an
que l'invasion brutale Yale de l'Ukraine
souveraine par la Russie a débuté
depuis monsieur le Président sous votre
houlette votre peuple tout entier a été
inspiré par votre courage lorsque l'on
parle lorsque l'on pense à l'Ukraine on
pense à des héros on pense à David
contre Goliath
on pense à tous ces combattants de Mario
Paul on pense à tous ceux qui ont libéré
des villes des villages
occupés
pendant des générations et des
générations on se rappellera leur nom
les bombes continuent à tomber tous les
jours sur votre pays et pourtant vos
céréales continuent à nourrir le monde
après le tremblement de terre
dévastateur en Russie en Syrie vous avez
envoyé des sauveteurs vous avez envoyé
des experts ça c'est de la solidarité
réelle
[Applaudissements]
que la maison de la démocratie
européenne
s'est députés notre Union européenne ont
toujours été de votre côté
nous comprenons que vous ne vous battez
pas seulement pour vos valeurs mais pour
les nôtres
pour nos idéaux les idéaux qui nous font
vivre nous tous comme sœurs comme frère
et qui font de nous tous des Européens
l'Ukraine c'est l'Europe
l'avenir de votre nation est à
l'intérieur de l'Union européenne
wino de sacrifice statue nous
connaissons les sacrifices endurés par
votre population pour l'Europe il ne
s'agit pas de les honorer simplement par
des mots mais par des actes par la
volonté politique pour faciliter tous
les échanges pour faciliter dans la
mesure du possible le plus rapidement
possible la procédure d'adhésion pour
aider votre population à reconstruire
pour former vos troupes pour vous
fournir des équipements des systèmes de
défense militaire il faut que vous
gagnez
et aujourd'hui
les États doivent envisager rapidement
de vous fournir le plus rapidement
possible les avions de combat dont vous
avez besoin
[Applaudissements]
notre réponse doit être
proportionnée par rapport à la menace
une menace
existentielle
quand j'ai grandi
les grands-parents me racontaient
l'histoire de notre pays nous avions
trois avions de combat à un moment où il
n'y avait plus de munitions plus d'un
plus rien à manger il nous restait la
foi l'espoir et la charité et nous nous
sommes battus nous avons continué à nous
battre chaque avion représenté un jour
de liberté de plus en attendant que
l'aide arrive
l'aide arrive et la paix vous n'avez pas
besoin de nous convaincre du caractère
essentiel de notre soutien à l'Ukraine
pour aider ceux qui sacrifient leur vie
qui soutiennent les valeurs pour
lesquelles nous nous battons tous avec
des mesures con pour avoir une paix
véritable s'appuyant sur un véritable
programme en 10 points et en demandant
une reddition de comptes pour tous les
criminels de guerre garantissant la paix
et la liberté pour tous les Ukrainiens
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais vous rappeler la promesse
que je vous ai faite au mois d'avril
dernier lorsque nous nous sommes
rencontrés à Kiev nous sommes avec vous
nous étions avec vous nous sommes avec
vous et nous serons avec vous aussi
longtemps que nécessaire la liberté va
l'emporter la perte va l'emporter vous
allez gagner slavancraining
[Applaudissements]
cela va ou Klein
madame la Présidente
merci pour ces propos forts
[Musique]
de la tension jamais démenti que vous
avez porté à titre personnel à l'Ukraine
merci
pour votre approche
énergie merci pour tous vos efforts
merci pour votre aide inflexible merci
pour le soutien de l'Europe durant toute
cette période
c'est la seule façon pour nous
d'aller de l'avant
l'Europe a de la chance que cette
Peinière qui se tient en plus grand
Parlement démocratique du monde puisse
avoir une majorité absolue qui soutienne
les principes qu'une défendons ça
[Applaudissements]
les représentants et représentants de
l'Europe Mesdames et Messieurs les
dirigeantes et dirigeants européens
citoyennes et citoyens
vous êtes à la fois les représentants de
l'Europe vous êtes les dirigeants de
l'Europe
ce que vous êtes cette dualité
représente la paix et ce que l'Europe à
offrir au reste du monde
une un mode de vie un mode de vie
européen
NES de vie une façon de vivre
ou l'individu
et le droit prévalent
ou les États et les sociétés
essaient de s'entraider et comprennent
leur diversité de valeur
où les valeurs des différentes
personnalités se conjuguent
ou les frontières ne sont pas violées
où vous ne ressentez pas cependant que
vous franchissiez des frontières ou les
gens ont confiance en eux et sont prêts
à descendre dans la rue pour défendre
leur avenir
la seule barrière que vous ayez ce sont
les élections qui doivent être honnêtes
c'est le seul c'est le seul contrôle qui
existe c'est ça l'Europe c'est ça la
façon de vivre de l'Europe pour nous en
Ukraine
c'est notre maison
c'est le chemin que nous voulons
défendre ce chemin vers notre maison
[Applaudissements]
je me présente devant vous aujourd'hui
pour défendre
cet accès à cette maison cette porte
d'entrée
tous les Ukrainiens quelle que soit leur
âge leur convictions religieuses leur
statut social tout le monde chez nous
partage cette volonté nous avons toutes
et tous des histoires différentes mais
nous avons une histoire commune c'est
celle de l'Europe nous sommes européens
le mode de vie
ukrainien le mode de vie européen sont
remis en danger
pourquoi sait-on de les annihiler par
une guerre totalitaire parce que une
fois que l'Ukraine tombera c'est votre
mode de vie qui tombera le vôtre celui
des 27
États de l'Union européenne votre mode
de vie disparaîtra après de notre nous
devons pas permettre ceci
qui a été lancé par la Russie
n'est pas qu'une simple guerre de
conquête territoriale
dans un coin de l'Europe
la véritable menace c'est de voir un
dictateur
qui possède des réserves énormes
d'armement de l'air soviétique qui se
voit fournir des armes de régime
dictatoriaux comme l'Iran pour pouvoir
poursuivre sa guerre et de façon cylique
et délibérée année après année étape
après étape le Kremlin a essayé de
détruire d'annuler ce que nous
considérons comme une valeur essentielle
en Europe celle du respect de la vie
humaine en Russie la vie humaine ne
compte pas personne n'a de valeur à part
celles et ceux qui sont au kemelin et on
leur portefeuille comme valeur
140 millions de citoyens russes
ne sont que de la chair à canon des gens
qui sont simplement appelés à porter une
arme une arme qui sera présente sur le
champ de bataille des soldats obéissants
c'est la suprématie de l'obéissance de
la violence voilà la règle que veut
imposer le ce n'est pas le droit
le régime russe non seulement déteste et
la justice sociale la diversité
ils investissent dans l'accès nos phobie
et essaie de faire de celle-ci normalité
sur notre continent
ils essaient de rendre l'image la règle
d'en faire une réalité au XXIe siècle
mais nous ne voulons pas de cela non
Europe nous voulons défendre autre chose
nous voulons défendre
l'Europe face aux forces les plus
anti-européennes du monde avec vous sur
le champ de bataille
il y a déjà Cobra
je voudrais vous remercier
je te remercie de nous aider à nous
défendre et à vous défendre nous nous
défendons nous vous défendons
c'est important pour vous pour vos
sociétés
quel que soit votre nationalité ou qui
vous êtes nous voulons toujours lutter
contre le manque de respect
que nous soyons nous devons toujours
miser sur l'intégrité
quelle que soit l'avenir dont nous
rêvions pour nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants la précondition de ce
rêve c'est la paix et la sécurité
ce possible
ne s'avérera que si nous battons les
forces anti-européennes qui essaient de
vous dérober cette Europe que vous avez
créé seul notre victoire vous garantira
cela
seul notre victoire vous garantissait
rationnel chacune des valeurs
européennes que vous avez conquise
qui doit être préservé
mesdames et messieurs les dirigeants de
l'Europe
parlementaire européen fonctionnaires
européens journalistes ici présent
service de sécurité qui travaille
beaucoup
policiers militaires
sauveteurs
diplomate
professeur enseignant scientifique
médecin
chauffeur
travailleur agriculteur
travailleurs dans l'industrie patron
employé salarié
employé de banque travailleur de
l'énergie des réseaux électriques
syndicalistes
citoyens représentant des ONG
acteur producteurs juristes
défenseur des droits de la personne le
destin de l'Europe
n'a jamais autant dépendu
des politiques que maintenant
tout le monde à son rôle à jouer tout le
monde parmi vous doit être fort tout le
monde parmi vous est capable d'avoir une
influence concrète
sur un résultat concret pour une
victoire commune
et
vous m'applaudissez mais c'est pas moi
que dire
vous devez applaudir
toutes celles et ceux
les centaines de milliers de personnes
qui ont soutenu l'Ukraine
dans cette bataille historique merci
[Applaudissements]
merci
toutes et tous
celles et ceux qui nous ont aidés notre
peuple nos citoyens les gens qui que
vous avez accepté ici
qui ne vous demandons de continuer de
nous aider d'accroître votre aide pour
protéger ceux qui ont trouvé refuge chez
vous celles et ceux qui posent des
questions celles et ceux qui s'opposent
à l'agression russe celles et ceux qui
refusent par exemple d'accepter des
informations russes vous devez les aider
c'est une question de vie de mort et
d'Europe merci
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais remercier remercier toutes
celles et ceux qui ont aidé l'Ukraine en
leur fournissant des armes des munitions
de l'énergie des générateurs du
carburant
autant de matériels
que nous pourrions réunir pendant cette
guerre que nous n'avons plus en dire je
vous remercier de tout cœur
à vous parlons des Européens toi Roberta
merci de cette décision de vouloir
défendre le mode de vie avec acharnement
avec hargne de défendre le mode de vie
européen
[Applaudissements]
vous avez prouvé par vos décisions
courageuses
par votre force
que vous pouviez être une maison de la
justice de la liberté je me souviens
des premiers jours de l'invasion ou
l'Europe menaçait de casser les Chine de
l'Europe
et je suis certain
que l'agression russe
va se casser les dents face à nos
défenses
le sixième jour déjà de l'invasion russe
vous avez retenté une résolution
simplement pour soutenir par des mots
notre lutte mais pour accepter le statut
de l'Ukraine comme Candida à l'adhésion
et ceci est une vision qui a modifié
notre pays qui nous a motivé à être plus
fort à nous battre
encore merci
se renier aujourd'hui
le Conseil européen va se réunir et
j'aurai l'occasion de remercier
personnellement les chefs d'État de
gouvernement
pour leur décision courageuse
cette dernière année qui a qui ont
permis à notre
continent de faire ce que on pensait
impossible c'est à dire que vous vous
débarrassiez de la dépendance coûteuse
de
l'Europe vis-à-vis de l'énergie russe
des oligarques russes vous avez prouvé
que vous étiez capable de vous défendre
vous avez que vous étiez capable de vous
défendre face aux infiltrations des
services secrets russes qui considèrent
le rock comme un terrain de chasse
il leur permettant de lutter contre ses
propres opposants pour la première fois
l'Union européenne a été militairement
un tel niveau un pays
c'est la première fois aussi
que l'on voit
autant de volonté de réformes au sein de
l'Union européenne pour se moderniser
pour se réformer pour se réformer ses
institutions également nous aussi nous
essayons de nous approcher de l'urbaine
nous voulons devenir mandol l'Union
européenne l'Ukraine souhaite participer
à cet effort l'Ukraine veut gagner
gagner son adhésion
dans une Europe qui gagne
[Applaudissements]
certains parmi vous n'ont peut-être pas
ressenti précédemment
la puissance du mot mode de vie mais
ensemble les pays de l'Union européenne
et l'Ukraine
on conjugué leur force on conjugué leurs
efforts pourquoi ceci a-t-il été
possible parce que nous avons combiné
une approche de principe énergique selon
laquelle nous étions tous égaux ne
représentons tous à notre façon
l'intégrité de l'Europe
nous savons que tout le monde tous les
dirigeants de l'Europe
veulent défendre une idée
nous ne voulons pas
perdre du temps nous voulons pas baisser
les bras nous ne voulons pas perdre
nous voulons pas perdre les acquis de
l'Europe nous voulons que l'Europe reste
l'Europe et ceci n'est possible que tant
que nous restons soudés et vous et nous
que nous entretenons l'ordre que nous la
nourrissons et nous nourrissons sans
mode de vie encore une fois merci et je
vous invite toutes et tous
gloire à l'Ukraine
[Applaudissements]
en très peu de temps à volody
merzelinski qui vient donc de s'adresser
au parlementaire européen
et qui est en train de recevoir des
mains de Roberta mezsola alors c'est un
symbole très fort c'est le drapeau le
drapeau européen Caroline effectivement
c'était un discours de volodi mirski sur
sa volonté